німецький джеймс бонд на комбайні посеред
червоної площі грузинка німецького кіно
тиля швайгера zuhvala нік безстрашний то
брутальний комісар німецької поліції про
поняття в Москві знайдете вати вкраду
торговцям та людьми данину утю ми йому до
допомагаючи комісар московського карнаву
рошку тіла факту дашкіна україни
пострілу опухла і дід і слухати і
кінопродукції одні суперечки шин статті 15
уде
він уланова закону про кінематографію
самий проза барону фільмі в шоломі мережа
популяризації краще пропаганду органі
держави агресора на лижний вид краї
на похід дружина вирубаних якщо паршиво
сотня 91 руб у німецької
телерадіокомпанії ndr я каспер
промалювала стрижку засумнівалася а що
в горщику та в залі проглядатися і
фільм а джеф український за бруні сказано
про позитивний образ
фсб шнека то дереку фільмі є lash
& slide шикарному рошку а російські
поліцейські силоміць у духу кіно' кліше
виглядати залом без парадних і
тупуватий головний актор тіль швайгер на
кам'яну українську оборону німецька
продюсер це владні та авторські права
поки не ви вирішила що і про скажу в цьому
вусі рішення дашкіна україни від них
сам факт явності таке державна
цензури в Україні
с-б-н-т-в не травневий ідея chef культури
я не хочу вказувати і українцям що
індивід і себе читання low гладить і у
тему фільмі нехай пропаганду на карась
росіян ми ж можу тіла пошиту для кого
у тебе man виразно хто думаємо над
українським міркам та фільму на дачах виду
ті з оборони, а такі прориви цензури і
забезпеченої овеків емо фотографій
змістити свої точки зору українців
утримуюсь уру або готовий витрачати
і з оборони а джипів рикша малий бюджет
фільм в центр він вимив ікри такий на
адже на батьківщині зарахування кльош це
інший сорт але у rule авторі